weet jij al wat je gaat stemmen
ja toch helemaal geen nut
hij slaat helemaal naar de verrijkende
beslissingen worden daar in Den Haag genomen
maar het heeft impact hier in ons brabant
ik laat je zien wat partijen voor ons willen betekenen
met in deze video
groenlinks PvdA en forum voor democratie
eerst 1 nieuwe op de lijst
of ja eigenlijk 2 oude bekende die de handen ineenslaan
groenlinks en PvdA
met natuurlijk 1 groen karakter
we moeten verduurzamen
en ook moeten er 1 hoop nieuwe woningen bijkomen
vooral voor de sociale huur
de brabander nummer 2
esmalalla uit Tilburg
ze zetten zich in voor armoedebestrijding
en zorgen in 2022
bij de gemeenteraadsverkiezingen ervoor
dat groenlinks van 6 naar 10 zetels ging
het esmalada effect
daar hoopt de landelijke fractie
nu van mee te profiteren
hopelijk
draagt ze de groen oranje sjaal nog op het Binnenhof
aan de andere kant
forum voor democratie
met 1 sterk nationalistisch karakter
zij willen de klimaatwetten juist intrekken
er moet 1 asielstop komen van 10 jaar
en de partij is tegen gendergelijkheid
ook moet 1 maximumsnelheid op de snelweg
weer naar 130 kilometer
per uur
als voor laatste op de lijst vinden we Ramon van as
1 bloei fanatieke fvd'er die via de jongerenpartij
zijn plekje veroverde op de lijst
deze nummer 19 komt uit zijn microcestel
is grootliefhebber van de binnenstad van den Bosch
fiverries 4 jaargetijden en de geur van lavendel
oké dat laatste weten we niet zeker
dat was 1 grapje
benieuwd wat andere partijen willen
bekijk dan de hele video op ons YouTube kanaal